"Hey, give it back!"
"Why?"
"You don't need any more!"
"You're a disgusting, fat pig!"
"Mom! Jeff called me a
disgusting, fat pig!"
"Jeff! Do not call your sister a fat pig."
"Well, she is turning into a little a little porker."
"See? Even dad thinks you're a fat pig."
I was teased a lot because
I'm overweight.
A lot of it was behind my back, but then
a lot of it was also to my face.
Which, made me feel terrible.
"Hi."
"Wouldn't it be quicker if you just smeared that on
your thighs?" /laughter/ "Yeah, can you say 'carbs'?"
"Meg, you're blocking the sun."
"Wait, you got a little chocolate right there." /laughter/
I know i'm not the only one. This sort
of thing happens all the time.
My name is Emme, and as the first plus-sized
supermodel, trust me! I
know what it's like to be judged based
on my size!
But i'm also a mom and now one of my
life's greatest passions is to be a part
of creating a world where children can
grow up happy, successful and fulfilled
at any size. I hope you are willing to
join me in that effort. During this
program we're going to take a look at
what weight bias is, how it shows up at home
and school,
who its victims and sources are, what its
consequences are and what we as parents
and teachers can do
to improve the lives of children
we're surrounded by.
But first, let's take a look at how prevalent
this problem is.
Obesity in children and adults has
doubled in the past twenty years.
Alarmingly, it's tripled in teens.
One in five American children is
overweight and overweight children
tend to become overweight adults.
Thirty percent of adults are obese.
And we're right on track for this trend to continue.
There are many efforts underway to address
childhood obesity,
but we aren't going to solve the
nutritional and lifestyle changes that plague our
nation in the
next twenty minutes,
but,
what we are going to do
is share with you some new perspectives
and tools that can help you
as parents and teachers
stem the tide
of prejudice in our school system
and even at home so that children do not remain
vulnerable to the negative impact of
bias and stigma.
And so that we may all
begin to treat many overweight and obese people
already in our lives fairly.
"Hey Ralph!"
"What's that? Your lunch box?"
/laughter/ "Ralph."
"Hey Ralph." /laughter/
Peers are frequent perpetrators of
weight bias, with school being the most
common setting.
Teasing can be in the form of verbal and
physical aggression as well as social
exclusion.
Many students face this torment daily. It
takes a toll on their emotional and
physical health
and reduces their quality of life.
One study even found that the quality of
life for obese children is as low as
children with cancer.
"My friend, um, was picked on
by a teacher,
who, he called her,
um, like, chubby and stuff,
and i just thought that was
very uncalled for, and a teacher
shouldn't say anything like that.
Twenty four percent of overweight boys
and thirty percent of overweight girls
experience prejudice in middle school.
That bias doubles in high school where
fifty-eight percent of adolescent boys
and sixty-three percent of adolescent
girls are the victims of peer teasing.
"Oh God,
here comes the earthquake."
I've heard my friends
talking about
a girl who's only slightly heavier than me
and, like, making fun of her, and it
makes me wonder what they said behind
my back.
Unfortunately attitudes towards weight
among children worsen over time.
We know that weight bias begins as
early as age three in preschool and
continues throughout elementary school,
middle school, high school and even college.
So overweight and obese children are vulnerable
targets of weight bias throughout their
educational careers.
Studies showed that children as young as
three years old
view overweight peers as mean, stupid,
ugly, unhappy, lazy,
having few friends,
and undesirable as playmates.
This all just based on the size of their
bodies by three years old!
Where does this come from?
Weight stigma comes from a series of
experiences that people have just
looking around them in their culture.
They see how their parents discussed the
issue of weight, they see how their peers in schools discuss it,
they see overweight people ridiculed
on television shows and made fun of by
comics and the like,
and because of this, um... they
develop quite negative attitudes,
they're very difficult to change.
By the time the children are in high
school and college they're experiencing
multiple forms of weight bias
not just verbal comments or physical
aggression, but also relational
victimization in the form of social
exclusion.
A lot of people assume
that overweight people are dumb
or lazy
but most of the time that's not the case.
In fact, I do well at school, I get good grades,
I'm part of the drama program, I
exercise, and I dance after school, so
it's not,
in most cases, it's not true.
People are afraid of what's
different from them.
And so by making them as less of
a person
then i guess they feel empowered.
Behind their back they might talk about,
'Oh, look at that shirt she was wearing. Her
stomach's popping out and everything. I can't
believe she'd even think of wearing
something like that.'
They'll just say, like, all these, like
fat jokes about like
wide load coming through and all
this stuff and it hurts me to see people
getting treated, because I see how sad
they are.
Most of the comments I get from them,
because some of them are my friends, they
say they heard comments like that
before and you just get used to it.
And that's a problem,
that you're getting used to it,
that's something you're not supposed to
get used to.
From nursery school through college
overweight students experience ostracism,
discouragement,
and unfortunately even violence. For
overweight students, the school
experience is one of ongoing
prejudice, unnoticed discrimination and
almost constant harassment.
Overweight children are more likely
than normal weight children to be
victims of bullying.
Obese children ages twelve to
sixteen
are more often the victims of repeated
group aggression
or mobbing.
And sadly, as a defense mechanism, some of
them resort to becoming bullies
themselves
because they have nobody to turn to for
support or help.
I've seen a couple kids that have been teased
turning into bullies because
they
basically are trying to get back at everybody that
has teased them and even people that
haven't teased them and
and it's just they wanna
put on his tough guy reputation
and it just turns them into bully.
The diet and beauty industries
bombard us in and day out with the
myth of the achievable perfect body,
perpetuating the cultural premium we
place on thinness.
I think they might think that fat people
are nasty just because they don't have
the body of a super model or something,
'cause super models don't even have
that body. They re-touch by computer so why
does everyone think everyone has to look like that?
Clothes shopping is
one of my least favrote
times of year. Like, going back to school and
having to get a new wardrobe and
lots of times
the clothes don't fit.
"I hate shopping!"
"Well, it might be fun if anything actually fit!"
"Let's just go home."
"You've got to find something,
you can't go naked!"
"Fashion's stupid!"
"Why can't I just wear something I
already have?"
"Because nothing you have fits."
It,
it makes me feel so, like
ugly.
Weight stigma, blame and intolerance are
not constructive motivators for weight
loss. They can actually have the opposite
effect.
Our research shows that social pressure
and stigma do not motivate weight loss,
and in fact, have the opposite effect.
For example we surveyed over twenty four
hundred adults who were overweight and
obese and asked them about their experiences
of stigma and we found that people
reported coping with stigma by eating
more food and refusing to diet.
My parents
try to be supported
but most of it just makes me feel worse.
They
say things to try and get me to
lose weight
but it doesn't help at all.
It kinda makes me want to eat more.
Victims of weight bias are more
susceptible to loneliness, depression,
anxiety, low self-esteem
poor body image and suicidal thoughts
and behaviors. Look at this list! Is
this what we want for our children?
Certainly not.
But this is what weight stigma gives
them.
A quality of life that no parent would
wish for their child.
We also know from research that children
who experience weight bias are more
likely to engage in unhealthy eating
behaviors, like binge eating,
and are more likely to avoid physical
activity, both of which may only
reinforce additional weight gain and obesity.
Ramifications of stigma on quality of life
continue into adulthood.
One study that I found particularly
alarming
was that women who were overweight as
children or teenagers still suffered
significant wage penalties even after
they lost the excess weight.
Weight bias is very socially acceptable in
North American society, it's rarely
challenged and often ignored,
and as a result, overweight and obesity
individuals have very little support when
they confront weight bias and as a result
may internalize negative stereotypes
and blame themselves for the negative
attitude that they see.
The stereotypes that characterized
overweight and obese people as dumb,
unsuccessful, stupid, or lazy, simply
aren't true! Think about the
overweight people already in your life!
Family members, friends, co-workers
children
Maybe even you've had a struggle with
your weight in the past.
We know that many people who are
overweight are intelligent, successful,
friendly and capable of achieving
the same goals as someone who is not
overweight.
People who are obese are just like
everybody else.
they live, they breathe, they think, they're just
like everyone else. Just 'cause they're a
little heavier than other people doesn't
mean that they're less of a person.
Maybe they may have a couple extra
pounds, but that's it.
Underneath it all, they're all just like us.
Expressing negative attitudes
towards obese people has become one of
the last accepted forms of prejudice
and could be as hurtful and difficult to
counter as racial prejudice.
Um, I see teachers, like, say something
in passing and they don't even realize
that it's offensive
and
the teachers are any better than the
students sometimes.
I found a lot of the teachers weren't as
sympathetic as i thought,
that you would imagine a teacher should
be,
and support really wasn't there
for some of his
his years
and it really hurt him, it hurt him a lot.
You just feel low, and you
just don't know what to do,
so you
make, you try to,
you try to comfort yourself with food
uh...
games inside all day or stuff like that.
Overweight youth are not only teased at
school
but peer harassment can come in the form
of verbal teasing, physical bullying or
social rejection from family members too.
"You're a disgusting, fat pig!"
"Well, she is turning into a little porker."
"Nothing you have fits."
What if your child is the victim of
weight bias?
Here are some suggestions of ways to
talk to your child about these issues
and find ways to intervene, offer support,
and help your child cope.
"Hey there."
"Hi."
"How was your day?"
"It was alright."
"Just alright? Yeah?"
I think one of the most important things
that needs to happen between a parent and
a child is open communication.
And that's really the groundwork that needs
to be set from the beginning. So you
want to have a relationship with your
child where they feel like they can come and
talk to you about a range of things.
So things are going well in their lives
and things that aren't going so well. And
one way to facilitate that is for the
parent to try to retain somewhat of a
neutral stance when their child starts
telling them about a difficult situation.
"These boys, uhÉ they called me fat."
"I don't really know who they are."
"Oh, sweetie, I'm sorry. I'm sorry that happened."
"When did that happen to you?"
"At lunch."
If your child has had their
self-esteem damaged through a
situation where someone has
discriminated against because of their weight
or bullied them because of their weight.
I think parents need to be very direct
and tell them
that
A) that they did not deserve to be
treated this way
and also to remind them of all the
strengths they have as a person.
"So how did that make you feel?"
"It really hurt."
"I feel like no one was there for me
or had my back."
"You know I have you back
always, right?"
and uh... you know
Mrs. Johnson, your English teacher?
I think she's somebody you could go to
and turn to. She loves you, you know that."
"She said, she said such lovely things about
you at the open house."
"Okay, and I think that's someone you can
trust and turn to."
"Alright, sweetie?"
"Okay."
Well fortunately schools have
developed policies and procedures to
deal with bullying in recent years
they're much more aware of these
problems.
So it makes sense for the parent to work
with their child
on a plan to go to the school talk with
a guidance counselor, a principal, maybe a
trusted teacher and really think about
the best way that the child should
handle themselves in school to avoid
future situations.
So, what can we do? At home or in
the classroom?
As parents and teachers?
There's a lot we can do.
The first step ti
changing any stereotype or
eradicating prejudice
is to be aware. Start paying attention to
your own attitudes about weight. Educate
yourself about the causes of obesity so
that you will be informed. So that you
can help your children and students
understand the various causes of obesity.
The causes of obesity are very complex.
It is a combination of genetic factors,
environmental
factors, psychological factors and it's
important to recognize that so that
when we look at someone and we see whatever
their body weight is, we don't make
assumptions about their behaviors
based on that information.
There's genetics involved, it's not just
like eating too much,
because I eat better than
a lot of people that I know and I
exercise more.
It's just the way I am.
Another thing people can do,
parents and teachers in particular,
to change the environment
of our children is what we call, avoid 'Fat-Talk'.
And 'Fat-Talk' kinda goes like this,
it's when one person says "Oh, I feel so
fat today."
And then the other person says, "Oh no, you're
not fat, I'm fat. Look at my thighs."
And then the other person says, "Oh no, your thighs look great.
I'm the one who's really fat."
This is a problem
because when people talk this way, they are
communicating to children that
number one, your body size is a very important thing, and
number two, that how you feel on any
given day is going to be related to
whether or not you're feeling fat that day.
Be alert to both overt and subtle forms of
peer harassment that occur in the
classroom or on the playground. And intervene
when you see weight-based teasing.
Encourage your students to intervene and
stand for their peers.
"Wouldn't it be quicker if you just smeared that on
your thighs?" /laughter/
"Yeah, can you say 'carbs'?"
"What's your problem?"
"What are you, the pig's keeper?" /laughter/
"Just leave her alone, okay?"
"Fine, whatever."
My brother's saw people
making fun of me in school one day
and he came and he stood up for me,
and it makes me feel good to know that
somebody accepts me for who I am.
One problem right now is that it's very
rare for children to see role models
who are not very thin or do not have an
ideal body type.
So one thing parents and
teachers can do is they can really seek
out this sort of individuals
and hold them up as role models for
children so they can look in the media,
they can look into sports,
or other celebrities and find
people who can serve as role models and
really represent very diverse body types.
Be sensitive to situations of potential
embarrassment for overweight students.
I actually spoke with a parent once who
told me about her daughter who was in
kindergarten
that when she arrived for school the
teacher had set up this special table
and chair
in a completely separate area of the
classroom off away from the other
children because the teacher felt that
the child would not fit into the regular
desks
This is really an example of how
it is communicated to the child: you don't
fit in here and you don't belong here.
Treat weight tolerance with the same
significance as you would racial or
religious tolerance.
Try to promote awareness of weight
bias.
Be a role model by enforcing a zero
tolerance policy of weight-based teasing in
your classroom.
"Oh God, here comes the earthquake!"
"Hey! You go, Ralph! Come on Ralph!"
/cheering/
At the Rudd Center, we work hard to
eliminate the problem of weight bias.
We believe that there's a strong
social injustice occurring here.
The hundreds of millions of people
around the world are deeply affected by
this and it just doesn't need to occur.
Race bias doesn't need to occur.
Gender bias doesn't need to occur and
weight bias doesn't need to occur.
We all want the same things for our kids,
don't we?
Happy, healthy childhoods.
Thank you so much for joining us today
and in the future as we strive to
improve the quality of life for our kids
through not just physical activity and
nutritious eating,
but by creating a world where we can
all can be successful and fulfilled
at any weight.
For more information please visit the
Rudd Center for Food
Policy and Obesity at YaleRuddCenter.org.